good afternoon everyone my name is a
beer as you can see you can tweet to me
there but you might want to also email
me because I don't check Twitter how
many of you guys can see the fourth
dimension okay great
none of you know what I'm talking about
after this so so this is what we're
gonna cover after this I want to tell
you a little bit about what data is made
of we all know that it's it's just
numbers but it's useful to think about
the structure in those numbers we're
going to talk a little bit about why we
don't care about understanding data as
opposed to maybe just shoving it through
some prediction engine we're going to
talk about the basic principles of data
analysis I want to introduce you to the
data space which is kind of a space just
like what we live in but the fourth or
100 dimensional space where you can
actually picture these data points in
then we'll talk a little bit about
k-means clustering pca discussed the
intuition behind tease me and then I'll
give you my ten steps to being a data
scientist patent pending so what is data
made of it's just it is just numbers
right we don't really need to think
about it any more than that but what's
important is the structure so images can
have pixel values for each location
audio signals can have intensities and
frequencies and intensities at different
points in time and data bases of course
are just kind of rows and columns that
contain information because of the
structure in them otherwise it's just
random letters and numbers so the
structure of course can get arbitrarily
complicated um I think it's important to
remember why we also want to understand
data besides wanting the technology of
using it we don't just want to push it
through an engine get predictions have
benchmarks and accuracy and sting things
like that but because data is really the
experimental observation of the present
it is the foundation for any kind of
understanding or learning that we can
get from anything that we observe so
these are a few differences between just
raw data and understanding that I've
compiled from various kinds of insights
I think it's important again to remember
that understanding is based on
hypotheses that can be tested it's based
on uncertainty and data is just the raw
number the raw observation data has a
stagnant structure whereas understanding
is kind of mutable you can apply it to
different contexts you can infer it in
different cases and data has no real
basis in science or learning you need to
extract understanding from these
observations to really have any kind of
science or learning and that brings us
to kind of the simplest thing that you
might ever be able to say when you look
at data which is that a data point if
you know nothing else about it it's
probably symbol similar to data points
that are near it and data in general can
then be looked at and you can try to
find patterns in it that give you meta
information which contributes to our
understanding and our learning and our
science so that brings us to the concept
of the data space which because we can
all picture two dimensions and we see
each other in two dimensions which
sometimes looks like three it's a neat
trick of the brain it's easy to think of
two dimensions so each row is just
basically a sample it's just a point and
it has two properties which kind of form
the two dimensional space as you can see
here you plot it and each of these
attributes actually have a value that
manifests all of this information in a
space of course we assume that each of
these properties is equally important
and is about scale to the same value
because if you're comparing say salaries
with eyebrow thickness you might have
extremely different values you could
have again here I've shown Birds and
their weights and Heights and you could
have a variety of different properties
that you're looking at Capital One might
care a lot about this and supply chain
companies and Amazon in particular might
care a lot about stuff like this so we
can extend the concept of actually
trying to manifest this information in a
space to three dimensions and it becomes
a little harder to visualize this I mean
you can't really get the sense of where
these points are what their relative
locations and distances are from each
other and things like that in three
dimensions
that actually doesn't stop the concept
of this space from being useful which is
what I want to walk you guys through
today high dimensional data can just
basically have a huge number of columns
or attributes and you can still
technically plot it in a space you just
can't see that space you might have to
ask Christopher Nolan to help you with
that
every row is still a point it has a
number of attributes and you can think
about this space and now we come to the
point where I tell you how that's useful
so let's think about one of the things
that that kind of translates naturally
from the two-dimensional space where
data points are kind of similar to other
data points that are near them one of
the useful things that you get from two
dimensions is that you can plot stuff
and you can actually immediately
identify inconsistencies because why are
the shorter Birds heavier and the taller
Birds lighter this doesn't make sense
right so either you have some kind of
biological anomaly or you probably made
a mistake somewhere and you'd like to
fix it so visualization is always kind
of important and it's useful and it
helps you kind of ground your your
conclusions in in some kind of base
intuition so once you fix it you can
kind of identify again that there are
two broad clusters here and that
correlates well with something that you
would expect biologically right male and
female birds this is something that you
can see in two dimensions but what about
when you have high dimensional data and
when you can't actually plot points in
this space you would like to have some
kind of objective metrics some kind of
hard core mathematically defined metric
for putting these points together and
saying hey these are closer and those
are closer and this is how we cluster
them separately
that brings us to k-means clustering
which is a really simple and powerful
way to do this before we get into
k-means clustering i want to remind you
guys that k-means clustering is based on
the metric of distance so we can think
of distance as in you're sitting there
and I'm sitting here and these are the
distances between us and that does make
sense in certain contexts but it's
important later on to think about the
contexts in which this distance might
not make so much sense
so k-means clustering basically just
takes your whole data set and
you tell it the number of clusters that
you'd like to identify in it and it just
gives you a list saying okay each of
these data points corresponds to one of
the whatever K clusters you asked me to
find and it does this again based on
some notion of similarity how close are
data points within the same cluster to
each other and then it it runs a an
algorithm until convergence the
animation on the right is actually going
to make that a little intuitively clear
to you I'm not going to run deep into
the math so these are the four initial
clusters the green points and it looks
at the points that are closest to them
and it just finds the centroid of all of
those points and says okay that's our
next Center and it keeps doing that
until some sort of convergence and says
okay based on these four converged
points so to speak I can identify
clusters based on what points are
closest to them if this sounds simple
that's because it is but it turns out to
be extremely useful
I'm sure Capital One has built lots of
layers of cool stuff onto this but it's
actually the basis for a lot of systems
that approve loans automatically they
decide whether you're gonna pay them
back or not
customer behavior and how to classify
different customers tumors somehow have
a whole range of parameters that you can
just shove into a k-means clustering say
hey these are cancerous so the ones
around that are probably cancerous image
classification is not so cool anymore
and students again basically any kind of
behavior can actually be clustered
really well using k-means clustering
which which is weird because you don't
necessarily expect the concept of a
distance to make sense in all of these
contexts but it has in these cases so
Who am I to argue
it does have limitations of course it's
not reproducible because you kind of
pick these four random points and then
wait for it to converge the real
clusters by which I mean what the data
shape is in the real high dimensional
space might not actually map well onto
this concept it might have you know a
non spherical shape like a boomerang and
then you're saying oh it's in the middle
of the boomerang but it's spread into
this weird kind of curve in a high
dimensional space and then you of course
have the problem of outliers this the
implementation in Python is exceedingly
simple so
you literally just have to google it
let's now move because I I kind of set
this up I said hey we can use distance
but that's not the greatest thing to do
and here's what I think is really cool
which is what PCA uses it looks at the
concept of variance so if you guys are
familiar with statistical variance
that's essentially what PCA is based on
and this is gonna give you a little
intuition on why that works so well so
because the distance between these
points might not always be the best
measure of their similarity you might
want to think about how much they're
spread over space so if all of you who
were just sitted seated on one chair
there would be really low variance there
would be very little information in your
positions as say 50 people but it's
because you're spread out that there's
more information about your locations
right so the informated ness of this
data is kind of measured by how spread
out you are and that's what PCA uses it
looks at the direction that your data is
kind of most spread out in and it's
really cool to think of how this
statistical concept that you might have
been annoyed and had to calculate in
some course at some point actually
translates so usefully to what the most
informative angle literally to look at
your data from is the most information
directly in formative Direction which is
kind of what it's less spread out along
and when you look at variance I want to
get a little quantitative about this so
that you can you you can really see how
it helps I want to look at the
projections of these points onto the x
and y axes and that's basically just how
we project things and then you kind of
look at the counts of these and you can
see that they're spread out along both
of these axes along the height axis you
have a few of those points with lower
values a few with higher values and if
you were to try and cluster these even
with k-means clustering you'd see that
there are actually clusters along both
of these axes right but when you look at
the data in the two dimensional space
you see that you only really need two
clusters you don't have to look at these
four cases and PCA looks at variants
as a way to reduce the number of
dimensions that you really have to
consider so let's look at the actual
values of variants for height and weight
that's the formula that you might have
hated at some point so the actual values
for along the high taxes and the way
taxes are about 15 and 19 and now I want
to take you to instead of using both of
these directions how we can even use an
arbitrary guess for you know some kind
of incline that might be explaining this
data which would allow us when we
generalize it to higher dimensions to
actually not use all of our hundred
columns but to say hey you know what
these are the ones that kind of matter
and in fact not just these ones but
these ones in a certain combination
which is what you mean by an angle or a
direction in space so let's pick this
random hybrid direction that I just kind
of did because it's convenient project
the points down onto these directions
like we did onto the x and y axes before
so each point now has a coordinate on
this new axis this is 11.6 units for
this particular point and you can
calculate the variance of these
projections right and we had 19 and 15
something like that before and you see
that there's much more variance along
this direction it's about 27 and that
just shows that this direction is kind
of explaining how your data is spread
out it's saying that hey if you look at
this direction it tells me much more
than looking at these individual ones
and because the new direction explains
more of this data if you think about it
that's what you you want a feature that
explains your data to make predictions
based off right another useful way to
look at this is to look at how the
clusters kind of condense into just
needing one axis to to separate them out
and of course when you're moving to
higher dimensions this is kind of an
implementation point but you don't want
to have to look at the intersections and
all of these things so you'd like to
Center all of your data around the mean
which is why you would subtract the
averages of all of these different
values in each dimension from your data
set you'd like to have it centered
around 0 as you can see here
and that helps you find these directions
of maximum and minimum variance so when
you actually run PCA you would find
these two directions which wasn't the
arbitrary one that I found which gave
you 27 as the variance you got 30 and
1.4 four which is significantly
different from just what your data was
plotted on which is height and weight
with about 15 and 19 so PCA basically
generalizes this to n dimensions just
like k-means clustering looked at how we
can circle the cluster and say that's
the cluster it uses linear algebra and
it's there's a lot of jargon again I'm
not going to get into the details of the
mathematical implementation but this is
basically what it does and this is the
input you'd basically just again shove
your database in to PCA and you could
optionally select the number of
principal components that you want to
identify but technically as you saw in
this example if there are two dimensions
then you would have that many number of
directions that would explain variances
in reducing orders there would be one
direction in a hundred dimension space
that explains the most variance and then
there would be a second that explains
slightly less and a third and there
would actually be a hundred directions
so the output would actually be those
directions in this case and because you
now have the directions you can find the
values of each of these data points
along each of these directions and that
gives you actually much more explained
ability in what what you're looking at
and that's why PCA is so commonly used
to identify features that are useful for
prediction I personally would advise
using it more for exploration because
otherwise you'd have to run PCA on your
data set every time it's updated but I
my main affinity with PCA is because of
how it really helps you explore your
data set and understand it in more human
terms and say oh these are the factors
that are actually explaining my data set
and this is where things matter and this
is where the variance is the highest so
again we're not gonna get into the
mathematical implementation but PCA is
also used for a huge number of
applications like I said feature
extraction because you want to not have
so many numbers to consider PCA helps
you reduce the number of numbers that
you just have to look at 2x
what's happening behavior classification
again data exploration it's really
interesting in general to just kind of
apply PCA to a dataset and to plot it
and if you have human understandable
analogues for Dilys coordinates to look
at how those different dimensions might
be influencing the space I'll show you
that with the Netflix example it's also
the preliminary processing for a lot of
applications because while you might not
want to use it immediately for feature
extraction to say oh these numbers are
more important it helps you kind of
develop an intuition for what your data
set looks like of course PCA also does
have limitations there's no guarantee
like I said based on where the points
are in the real space you don't know
that PCA is prioritizing the real
directions that explain it it depends
again heavily on the topology the
boomerang is always a problem and it
requires smart normalization because
like I said the eyebrow thickness might
not be a good comparison if you also
have tens of billions of dollars and it
is a black box because you would have to
apply it on a data set every time it
changes in order to reflect the changes
in the data set you can't do one small
tweak and say oh we added this point and
could you deal with that
so PCA is also extremely easy to
implement if you look at this the first
four lines are basically just getting
stuff ready and it's just two lines that
actually implement it it runs extremely
fast because it uses linear algebra
which data science at the hardware level
is in love with and let's get now to the
demo so the Netflix problem that I'm
going to talk about today is basically a
data set of customers and what movies
they might have watched so each row is a
customer and each column is a film and
if the customer has seen that film and
directed it then the number in there is
a the rating that they gave it and if
they haven't seen it there's just a zero
so I used the normalization to bring
this center to zero while also keeping
the films that haven't been seen at zero
so that clearly doesn't change anything
and this is because I want there to be a
kind of centric metric if like in
difference if you haven't seen the film
and a positive value if you liked it
more than you like the average film that
you've seen and obviously a negative one
if you didn't like it so what does
Netflix really want to do right it
to recommend to you movies that you
would want to see based on things that
you've seen before but it actually knows
not just what you've seen but what
everyone else has seen and if in some
high dimensional space it can look at
what really explains the difference
between its customers and then say hey
based on what puts customers closer or
farther apart in the sense of variants
if you're close to someone you probably
like movies that they liked so I know
where you are
I know who's close to you and I can now
recommend to you movies that they like
that you haven't seen it's rudimentary
and it's probably not what Netflix does
but it's a good example for how PCA
works and it's extremely useful to maybe
a business analyst or somebody who wants
to help a I start making films to
actually see how to generate appeal
because it's kind of getting into the
the nitty gritties of the problem and
extracting insight and understanding
from the data set that they have so yeah
so we're basically just using the same a
data point is known by the company it
keeps approach I want to ask you guys a
question why do you think okay I kind of
gave it away k-means clustering will not
be helpful here but why do you think
that might be
does anybody have any guesses okay so
it's because the concept of a distance
really would not translate well to a
space with maybe like 10,000 movies and
you liking one of them with a 1.3 and
you not having watched some of them with
a zero and you're disliking another with
a 2.3 how do you really use those points
in space and say okay the distance
between us is so much and that means
something it really doesn't mean
anything and that's why you kind of need
a measure of how points are spread out
in space where the concept of a
direction rather than a distance becomes
extremely useful so yeah that's a cue
for me to do the demo so here's the code
it is up on my github but all I'm doing
here is basically and everybody see okay
so I'm importing my data set I had to
run some pre-processing on it to make it
easy to read
sparse matrix and stuff like that but
this is the list of movie titles that
Netflix looks at there's dinosaur planet
and a bunch of other stuff that you
probably haven't seen this is me reading
my data set
it's a sparse matrix as you can see
these are the first few values of the
data set the the nonzero ones the code
here is just me kind of normalizing the
data again I only want to subtract the
average of nonzero values because I want
zero values to stay the same
I look at a zero as being no information
in difference and now I truncate my data
because I don't have infinite RAM and I
just look for the coordinates in this
space and this is actually the
coordinate in the data space because
each column is a movie these are the
movies and their values that explain the
most variance in the data in the data
set so you see that you probably don't
know a lot of these films right that's
something that I notice too and we're
going to get to why that is in just a
minute it might sound weird to us now
right because you'd expect that like
maybe super popular films should
actually decide who's there in the data
set and that should explain the
difference but if you think about for
one more second you realize that that
actually doesn't make any sense because
if everybody likes something that
doesn't explain any variance and if
everybody hates something it doesn't
explain any variance the real way that
you get to know a person is by asking
them a controversial question not by
something that you expect the answer to
with a great degree of certainty and
that's exactly what gets reflected in
the results of running this algorithm so
let's get back to the results so what's
the story what we find is that these
films that you probably haven't heard of
unless there are some really niche
tastes here all of these films are
actually called films they've had really
polarizing opinions they've had a pain
IMDb like it's great for old fans of the
show but still a 4 on 10 I didn't like
it but it would really resonate with
this small group of people and that
really explains variants in your
database right this is from Wikipedia
although critics were not impressed
audiences seem to love it
polarizing opinions things that are
really kind of different for different
kinds of audiences and that really pulls
your space apart that means that there
are some people in that corner of the
room and some people on that corner of
the room and that's the most information
mainly negative reviews from critics but
66 million that's nice
the majority of critics responded
favorably but Roger Ebert hated it so
that's the that's really the story that
PCA kind of uh nerds in your data set it
helps you not just maybe find the right
feature which I wouldn't honestly
recommend if you're putting something in
production but it helps you understand
your data it helps you get science and
understanding and knowledge from your
data so let's move now to tease me tease
me is is something that I feel deserves
honorable mention because it's actually
a lot more intuitive and robust than PCA
in a lot of ways but it does have some
limitations in how you can use it and
its implementation it's not as fast it
uses the concept of information theory
to actually look at in a high
dimensional space this becomes a little
easier to it's easier to understand why
this is important but it looks at what
points explain other points in terms of
how much information they carry about
each other so say in this
two-dimensional room people who are
sitting near each other are explaining
more about each other's locations and
that's easy to see and you'd say yeah I
guess they're also just closer to each
other
but if you bump this up into a hundred
dimensions it kind of doesn't translate
as much the like I said the notion of
distance doesn't make any sense when you
move to movies in this space and the
notion of actually explaining
information about each other using
metrics from information theory is
robust in that high dimensional space
that's what keys new uses just some raw
intuition on how this works which I hope
might help is to look at a histogram of
the distributions of
these points along each of these axes
and then to say hey it looks like these
two points kind of explain each other
well because they're close to each other
but a different way of saying that is to
say that they whoops represent that they
represent similar spaces in the
distribution and their distributions or
their frequencies are actually similar
to each other so that's just a little
bit of intuition on how to's knee works
to actually get into the depths of it
you'd have to understand something
called the Shannon entropy or a metric
of information but again the
implementation of T's knee is
exceedingly simple it's really easy to
use it's really easy to even just try
out on your data set as preliminary
exploration and with that I leave you
with my ten steps to being a data
scientist which is to just go in and get
your hands dirty figure out what an
algorithm does how to use it
shove your data through it because
you're not trying to put it in
production yet and understand these
algorithms because actually trying to
get into the depths of the mathematics
gives you much more insight it allows
you to generate knowledge and learning
and understanding which even if your end
goal is just to make predictions or to
classify stuff you will be able to do
better when you understand better the
problem that you're working on so I hope
I haven't been too mathematically
rigorous as you can see thank you very
much are there any questions
[Applause]
I sew for PCA and participe there's some
framers that you have to sit right so
huh PCA like the number out the clusters
and TC as well so like so with PCA
there's a the real parameter that you
only need to care about is how many of
these directions you're trying to find
so what ends up happening is that
oftentimes you'd set that parameter
based on how much you expect to be able
to compute in a reasonable time that
isn't the most scientific way to go
about it ideally you should start at a
really high value and degrade and also
increase and see how different your
performances are because PCA does give
you a measure of the explained variance
like I said we calculated the variance
along this new direction and we found
that it performed better than the
original directions PCA will give you
that explained variance and the rate at
which that explained variance drops off
as you add more directions is a really
good indicator of whether you're
reaching a good amount of detail so to
speak in your data set or not not not
necessarily because if you just have
like this spherical blob in a high
dimensional space then pretty much all
of your variances are going to be the
same but what you care about with PCA
usually is to try and not care about so
many of those directions so you would
like for there to be high variance on
your first one and then significantly
lower on the second and then
significantly lower on your third and
you'd really like for it to start
decaying to something relatively
negligible compared to the first one at
some point but if they're all kind of
large that probably is a sign the PCA
wasn't a good choice and that it's not
helping you as much as you'd like it to
have with Tizen II just to complete the
the answer there's a parameter call that
perfects perplexity which is again
information theory would help kind of
solidify these
analogies but it's kind of a measure of
how much of the default amount that you
expect things to be spread out so again
I would say to kind of play with the
results a little bit and to always start
with the point and have it much less
than that much higher than that have a
range but a hyper parameter exploration
I think was a part of one of the other
talks and it's a whole field on its own
so don't take my word for it yeah yeah
someone here so when clusters have like
kind of an inconvenient shape let's call
it it usually becomes really important
to kind of be able to visualize what
they look like and because you're saying
like if they're kind of being shaped and
you you're the data is kind of saying
that they're just one you'd only know
that their bean shape if you were kind
of able to visualize them and the really
nice thing about PCA is that it looks at
the directions that matter and then it
gives you the values of those data
points on each of those directions so
you can actually look at kind of the
shape of the data two dimensions at a
time you could look at the values of all
of your data points along the most
important direction and the second most
important direction and you get some
sense of how its spread out and then the
second and the third and the first and
the third and you could keep going like
that and that would actually help you to
identify if there's like this kind of
weird bean shaped structure as you call
it in in your data set right so so you'd
like to not just take k-means saying hey
all of these points are in one big
cluster you'd like to not take that at
face value
PCA helps you actually spread those
points out and see okay this is what's
happening this is what k-means said
about these points but when I plot them
with the most important directions
according to their variances this is
what it looks like and it's much more
spread out than I thought it should be
and that would help you then take your
next step
yep
and protect it back they do risk if your
data is not structured doesn't have
linear
mm-hmm that's a really good question so
I get this question the last part of
your question I get a lot which is that
Oh what if there isn't a linear
relationship in your data but PC
actually doesn't care about a linear
relationship between your data and what
you're trying to predict because PCA
doesn't say anything about what you're
trying to predict all it says is that
this is actually how your data itself
differs from itself so nonlinearities in
the data so to speak are not really a
problem because it's just looking at
kind of a spread one you really useful
way to think about pca is to think of
your data in this really high
dimensional space and then think of a
high dimensional ellipse or like a high
dimensional oval that kind of fits all
of it and then look at what the main
directions of those ellipses are I I'm
not sure if that analogy helps but as
you can see that has nothing to do with
whether there's a linear relationship
between the features in that space and
what you're trying to predict it will
still tell you that this is how your
data spread out but if there are
nonlinearities between those features
and what you're trying to predict you
would have to deal with them anyway it
PCA will only tell you that hey this is
what's different in your data from one
point to another and not from this point
to what it might be like a yes or no or
a male or a female or anything like that
hi are there any scenarios where I would
think differently
that's also a really good question so
personally I would say that especially
for feature extraction like PCA still
sometimes used I would not recommend it
at all on a sparse data set I would not
recommend it on binary data sets for
sure and discrete ones are still a
little dicey because what it's what it's
really only doing is showing me a spread
and telling me that these are the
components that matter on that spread so
I can use that gain understanding and
insight but if you're putting something
in production I would definitely not
recommend PCA on a sparse data set it
would not do a good job of actually
using that information or rather I
wouldn't assume that it's going to
always do a good job of extracting the
most important thing and sending it out
because at the base at the very basic of
it it's still using a different metric
called variance as opposed to distance
and that that just doesn't work well in
a sparse data set with a lot of zeros
that kind of pull your averages into
certain areas what it does do is
basically allow you to to probe the data
set and say okay what's happening maybe
this is the spread or this is the reason
that it varies along this axis and stuff
like that that there would be a lot of
problems with kind of trying to just use
this as a as a basis for identifying
features and pushing that into
production
[Applause]